[Musique]
alors ça raconte quoi tout ce qui nous
est arrivé depuis cinq ans
votre mari il a quoi comme problème un
accident frédéric s'est réveillée
aveugle je cherche un pack hiver qu'une
seule verte montayral beaufort annoncé
la dame qui centre de chirac on ne sait
pas si ça sera pas la boisson fromage
sans te fait il n'a pas perdu un peu
dire s'il est devenu obsédé par la
bouche c'est quoi c'est quoi je sais
quoi c'est quoi les maltais baboule des
maltesers c'est quoi j'en veux c'est
quoi c'est quoi c'est mon gardien
adverse moi je pense aux nuls
vous parlez de vos amis dans le vide
vous l'aurez finir encore que ça va leur
plaire
enfin s'ils reconnaissent mais c'est
vrai quoi on dit on est avec tel c'est
et ça a dit tu vas voir je suis tout
faire alors je viens danser rires c'est
vrai ça fait 20 ans qu'on vit ensemble
tu as bien une petite idée non ceci mon
livre vous a fait de la peine je suis
désolé
ce que je voulais écrire c'est que ce en
vue je sens mes enfants j'aurais jamais
tenues
regardons à spine nages il est pas
manchot il aveugle
à
c'est moi qui fais un c'est moi qui fais
je te dirais maintenant je te dirai je
te dis ok jean-luc temps tu le sens
non non non non
non